- Let's do this.
(audience cheers)
- Okay, Gary, first question.
Gonna keep it real easy, you
have 1.2 million followers on
Twitter, well done there, your
channel's all over the place.
Stitcher, Snapchat,
Facebook, YouTube,
iTunes, Soundcloud,
what's your favorite?
- My favorite, I think this is
similar to what a lot of people
asked me what my
favorite wine is, you know?
I don't necessarily
have a favorite.
I think we go through momentum.
I would think Twitter has
historically been my favorite
platform 'cause it's the easiest
one natively from a UI/UX
standpoint for me to engage
with all of you which is really
valuable to me.
Snapchat right now is you
know and obviously a lot of the
people in here who are either
watching or in the room know if
they follow me I'm very fond
of and what I really love about
that is when I have the chance
to reply one-on-one in that
environment, I get
even more of a lift.
To me, what I love social media
for is a little bit different
than I think most people.
I truly believe that most people
are way to over focused on the
distribution of their content in
that environment and for me I'm
very much focused on that
but I do believe that it is a
platform that allows for
scaling the unscalable,
the one-to-one engagements.
I know a lot more about the
people in this room they could
ever imagine and I think that's
how you build actual community
and depth and so for me the
tools that allow that the most
are the ones that are
most interesting to me.
And so, you know
I'll be honest with you,
even the change on Twitter to
the heart where I'm now instead
of like which felt weird like
some he says something nice.
It's amazing a
little subtle things work.
If somebody here said something
I never liked
anything on or starred.
I never favored anything on
Twitter that one here would say
about me but the heart because
of the way that works in the
other platforms is more of a
appreciation for you giving me
love and then it's a scalable
way for me to create context
with you to let you know
that I'm paying attention.
Tools that allow me
to prove that it's me.
I'm always
stunned how many people,
even after a decade, are still
questioning if I'm doing it.
So Twitter video,
Snapchat's incredible for that.
It's a place where I get to
prove I'm actually reading it.
I'm actually engaging with it
and so I think
that's super important.
So, my favorite ebbs and flows
but always my favorite thing is
the one that allows me to create
depth on a one-to-one basis
which then allows me to build
actual relationship with people
who then amplify organically the
stuff that
I'm actually pushing out.
I believe the work that I put
into actually have relationships
with the people I've known a
long time and things of that
nature create a scenario that
allows when I put out something
the threshold for them to share
it because it came for me is
probably little bit lower
because I have equity that I've
gained through not my words but
through my actions and so those
are the kind of like checks
and balances that
I'm trying to figure out.
- Okay.
In your opinion is
social media a marketing tool?
- 100%.
Anything the world that
has people's attention
is a marketing tool.
Like football jerseys
are a marketing tool because
you're looking at them.
Social media is a slang term
for the current state of the
internet and I think the
internet is a marketing tool.
- You say about
marketing tools and
social media
being a marketing tool.
I have like, I was thinking
of questions earlier today.
I've been going through other
questions of
people that asked you.
Through all the Q&amp;A's.
I was like, I want
to talk to you about VR
but in a different way.
- Okay.
- Facebook bought Oculus back
in 2014 and apart from doing a
little thing with Samsung and
obviously the 360° videos that
they're now
starting to roll out.
I want to know
your thoughts on this.
What do you think and
how do you think Facebook
are going to use that purchase?
What are they going do with
VR in a social media context?
- I personally believe that
Mark Zuckerberg is the single
best day trader of
attention in the world.
If you think about it
when he bought Instagram
for $1 billion couple years ago
I think you guys all might
remember everybody freaked out.
It was only 550
days old, the company.
A lot of people haven't even
created their Instagram account
yet and here's a billion dollar
exit several years ago when
a billion was more
than it is today, right?
Just to remind everybody,
I get a lot of credit
for being early on Snapchat.
18 months ago Mark tried to
buy Snapchat for
$3 billion, right?
$3 billion for Snapchat
where only now in the last 60,
90 days have
people said wait a minute.
He bought Oculus
because I believe,
and I don't
know this for a fact,
Mark understands that the only
arbitrage to the internet itself
is going to be VR.
So VR is not gonna arbitrage
social or how is it going to
work together, VR arbs
out the internet itself.
VR becomes the next
platform where our attention is.
You put on those contact lenses
and the reason for all of you
that follow me I keep saying
contact lenses it's an ode to
what I think is gonna happen
which is I don't think VR on a
consumer level is going to grow
as fast as a lot of people do
and by the time they do,
I don't think it's going
to be some conky headset.
I think we'll be into
contact mode in a decade when
I think it actually hits scale.
I think VR right now is far
more similar to internet 1992,
'93 then like tomorrow all of
you are gonna be watching your
movies and playing
video games on headsets.
That's too big of a jump.
You know, we're slow.
- Yeah.
- Like we're
slower than we think.
Like think about how
much you buy on e-com.
This is, by the way,
we're in the U.K.
This is a mature e-commerce
market and still think about how
much shit you buy
at the store. Right?
So we don't do things as
fast as people think at scale.
Obviously,
there's early adopters.
There's plenty of nerds in
Silicon Valley that are gonna
put headsets on and VR it out
but at scale I mean people in
this country side, right?
I mean middle America, that's
gonna take a much longer time
but the reason he
bought it is because
Zucks is playing for keeps.
Like Mark Zuckerberg's gonna run
Facebook until
he dies in his mind.
He's a young man and I think
he's more similar to a
Jeff Bezos like CEO where he
doesn't care if Wall Street looks
at the line item
of $2 billion and goes,
"You suck because there's not
as much profit this quarter."
He'll be thrilled for the stock
to go to 20 because he knows in
24 months a stock
will be at a buck, 20.
- Yeah.
- And when will we be
interacting with you on VR?
- You know, for me, I'll be
there as early as I think
there's enough meaningful
scale to get learnings from.
- Mhmmm.
- So you know a lot of
people are like you're so,
you predicted a
lot of things right.
You're so disruptor
or whatever, you know?
I think I'm practical.
I actually just wait like
I haven't predicted anything.
I've just moved very quickly
when Facebook or Twitter or
Tumblr or YouTube or email or
Google AdWords was at some scale
that was more meaningful
then the rest of you thought.
- That's like with
the Snapchat things.
Supposedly, it's not supposedly
you were looking at it in 2013
and people would always say
oh, he's only on it now.
It's like, you look at it,
you analyze the product.
You think do I do it, yet?
- The best thing that's going
on for me right now is with
Snapchat and with
DailyVee I'm document,
and The #AskGaryVee, I'm
documenting so much more of my
thoughts in depth.
So a lot of things that are
I know are gonna play out in
24, 36 months, I'm gonna have a
lot more video around then I did
with like one or two talks where
I talked about Snapchat three
years ago so I'm excited.
I'm excited that also a lot of
you can make fun of me in two or
three years on things
that I was wrong about.
I like the meritocracy of
having those conversations.
The reason I'm not scared though
is I don't really bet that hard.
For example, think
of it as real estate.
I'm not gonna go in the middle
of absolutely nowhere and see an
amazing beach and
there's no infrastructure,
there's no roads,
there's no airport,
there's no people but it's the
most gorgeous
beachfront I've ever seen.
I'm not gonna buy that property.
That's 20 years away but
where I would go is
that is that infrastructure.
I wasn't the first guy or gal
that bought there but I'm buying
it 36 months, 60 months
before it really pops.
That's how I play
in these platforms.
I'm not the first user.
I'm not the second user.
I'm on Peach right now, I'm
paying attention but I only have
to check it every 30, 60 days.
I'm not there
checking it every hour, right?
I'm paying
attention to Kik, right?
attention to these platforms.
I'm paying attention to Anchor.
You guys know this,
I've been throwing it out there
but I'm not there everyday.
I'm not
producing for it every day.
It's kind of over there.
I know about it.
I know why I'm paying
attention whether the founder,
whether the thesis, whether
consumer behavior but
I don't talk about shit
I don't believe in.
And so, I'm actually quite
boring for periods of time.
If some of you, met a really
tall young man back there he
said I've been watching since
episode 10 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
#AskGaryVee Show is funny to me.
If you watch the
first hundred episodes
all I talk about is Facebook.
Like it's so underpriced so and
then all of a sudden you know
episode 175 to episode 300 I'll
just talk a lot about Snapchat
and influencers on Instagram.
I don't need and then if you
talk to me about my pillars like
work ethic,
you know, self-awareness,
all this stuff,
I'm never gonna change.
Like I just want to, you know,
the lucky thing for me is the
world changes and I deploy my
thesis on the new thing but at
it's essence you can
get bored of me real quick.
- So if you were
starting out now,
where would you begin?
- Well, I would
reverse engineer myself first.
So, if you're sitting
out here and starting it now,
like A, you have to understand
that creating content is the
cost of entry to
being relevant in society.
Whether you're a person or a
business the creation of content
on these platforms is the
cost of entry to relevancy.
So the first thing I would do
is say what can
I do to create content.
Am I good at writing?
Am I good at video production?
Should I audio it?
I think everybody here is the
reverse engineer themselves.
For me, video is the
most powerful platform.
It's been proven.
Movie and TV stars are more
famous like this is just the way
it is. So I got lucky.
I light up when
the camera comes.
I get going.
I can't write a sentence.
I can't even imagine the jokes
my team makes at VaynerMedia,
I don't think I've even written
in the body of an
email in three years.
(audience laughter)
Everything I have to say
is gonna come in the title,
and that's
gonna be it and.
I don't even use
commas, I go dot-dot,
it takes me
longer to do what I do.
That's how bad my grammar is.
I'll go dot-dot-dot-dot, it
takes me longer than the comma.
I can't even get myself
to use commas because I don't
understand grammar and
so, so that's a bad idea.
So I think the first thing I
would do is I would sit here and
say how do I communicate and if
the answer is none of the above,
you should team
up with somebody.
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- Because you
have to communicate.
You have to
communicate and create but
it has to be authentic.
I often talk about
the 23-year-old,
24-year-old business coach
that's never built a business.
Like that pisses me off.
And so, I'd much rather a
24-year-old that wants to make
money off of people talk
about the journey of becoming a
business person 'cause that's
actually what they're going
through versus faking it.
I also think it's massively
important to put out content
around what you actually do.
In 2006, when YouTube was super
young and I'm about to start a
show this is early internet,
web 2.0 if you think
about where were talking about,
everything that people
watched was about tech.
It was Tech TV, it was Scoble,
it was Kevin Rose,
Diggnation and I'm like, "Shit,
I'm gonna do a wine show."
Wine show is not,
wine's not mainstream ever
and never will be.
I remember everybody after
it was successful was like,
"Oh, but you had a
great subject matter."
I'm like, "Do you know how many
fucking people care about wine?"
(audience laughter)
Like 11.
But I knew that I had a talk
about something authentic.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- In the same way that
I knew as things were evolving,
that in my heart is like
you know I don't want to be
America's wine guy.
There's a lot of people that
could be a better wine critic
and wine personality than me
but what I am good at is this
business marketing thing.
I better start producing content
from that 'cause that is coming
from an authentic place.
It's how I built all this.
- Yeah.
If you're like passionate
about something then it also
tells in the content
you create and you were and
you are extremely passionate.
- Yes.
But a lot of people confuse
my first story of Crush It!
You know, it's not like just
'cause you love football or
hip hop or roses that
you're entitled to build
a million dollar
business around that.
Passion is massively
important, I'll tell you why.
Work ethic is an absolute pillar
of variable to being successful.
And if you're
passion about something,
it doesn't feel like work.
And that's a big deal.
If you feel like if you're
working on your side hustle from
6 to 2 in the morning,
6 P.M., 7 P.M.,
right, and you're not up for
it like you're forcing yourself
because you need
the money or the dream.
You've fucked up.
You picked the wrong thing.
To punt all your leisure and all
your friends and family and to
work on something and to be
tired the next day 'cause you
have to get up for work which
you really don't want to do
which is why you're
building your side hustle.
That has to be about your
passion because it's just too
hard if it's not.
It can't be about
where you think you can
make the most money.
What I don't think people
understand is you can make a lot
more, like there's a lot,
so I wrote Crush It!
a long time ago.
The emails that I get, I get way
more people that are making 50
to 200,000 a year
talking at the craziest,
like the emails
I get are so bananas.
Like, well bananas is in my
Snapchat so I won't use that.
Like, "Hey, GaryVee,
you know, I read Crush It!
"in 2009 and
I'm making $74,000 a year
"in ads and selling T-shirts
around raspberry jam only."
(audience laughter)
I've had a lot more
people make money deep,
deep, deep in the
longest tail niche
that you could
have ever thought of.
Hip hop stars from 1986 to 1989.
This is a real one.
There's a guy who only talks
about hip hop from '86 to '89
'cause he was in high school
during those years and now he's
like now he gets paid like five
to $10,000 a month retainer to
do hip hop consulting for
companies that came from the
content he was putting out.
- That's so amazing.
- He stopped
being an accountant.
(audience laughter)
Right?
But the people
that are losing are,
I tried to build an
affiliate marketing company.
I tried to do $500 e-books.
They went for the money,
they had no patience.
The hip hop guy and the
raspberry jam girl and this guy
had years of nobody
giving a shit before we popped.
I did Wine Library TV for two
years with not with crickets.
Crickets.
- What kept you
going during that time?
- 'Cause I knew I was right.
- (laughs) That's
what kept him going.
He was right.
- That's exactly right.
I know and don't forget and
there was something else
that's a little, that's a little
bravado what I also had the
history of how
I built Wine Library.
Everybody said I was wrong
to do an e-commerce site.
My dad got scolded by his liquor
buddies saying you should open a
second store not
this internet fad, right?
When I didn't do a catalog like
everybody did catalogs 'cause
I was doing
email that was stupid.
'Cause catalogs were
the establishment of
how wine store sold product.
When I was buying Google AdWords
instead of doing more
direct mail and took
direct mail dollars out of that,
that was stupid 'cause
direct mail is what got us here.
What gets you somewhere is never
the thing that gets
you to the next spot.
- Yeah.
We good in the audience to
grab some questions
from you guys now?
- Oh, they'll roll.
- Microphone up.
- Yeah, let's give
those who got tickets first.
- Okay, raise your hand if you
want to ask Gary a question.
Louise, can you get to
the man in the blue there?
We'll come to the
front in a sec as well.
Introduce yourself,
your name and where you work
and what you do.
- [Warren] Hey, I'm Warren.
- Stand up, we can't see you.
Please.
- Oof, you work them hard.
- I'm not, what stand up?
- [Warren] What advice would
you give to one of the world's
biggest brands that has just
started selling products online?
- One of the world's
biggest brands that's selling
now direct to consumer.
- No, that is just starting to
sell our products direct online.
- Just starting.
- [Warren] Yeah.
- But before has been
selling it through retailers.
- In the wholesale market.
- So, first thing I would say is
make sure your channel conflicts
are all set and
you have no issues.
So one of the biggest issue in
the game right now is a lot of
big brands want to go direct
to consumer as infrastructure's
getting built up but if you
create a little bit of friction
between the people that actually
sell your products 'cause you're
arb'ing around them so first
I would say politically make
sure that what you're doing,
you don't try to like cut your
nose despite your
face because you have
to have those relationships.
Number two, I would say to make
sure that the people that have
been involved in the wholesale
business are not involved in the
DTC business.
That you need to create a
completely autonomous division
that understands that
because they are very,
B-to-B and B-to-C are very
different businesses and
require very different skills.
The other thing I would say is
please understand there's a very
big difference between being a
salesman and a transactor and
being a brander and a marketer.
One of biggest mistakes is
big brands go from into this
environment and then they're
taught that this is a quant play
and it's all math conversion and
all the things that helped them
build the biggest
brand in the world,
branding they punt and they just
care about last attribution,
you know, conversion based.
You know how many people in this
room did not jump on Snapchat
because they didn't understand
the ROI and how to convert the
ROI or understand what the ROI
was of the video 'cause there
was no direct attribution
in a digital environment.
'Cause they're salespeople.
Because they're transactors.
They're not branding
and marketing people, right?
Like these mother
fuckers right here,
they didn't cookie me no the
internet and follow me around
with banner ads and I gave up
and I bought this pair of shoes.
(audience laughter)
Right?
I bought these because I blindly
was fed it somewhere over the
last 30 years that this
is what I'm doing, right?
So big brands I think make
the mistake of going way too
transactional because they'll
bring in a separate team that
are digital marketers, that are
quant based and it's like last
touch on Google, last touch
on Facebook and they lose the
essence of branding and
marketing which would force them
then to make three and four
minute videos on Facebook where
they could do much
better commercials.
They could do content.
Where they would do Instagram
and Snapchat as
emerging platforms.
Where they would do content deal
so those are some of the pillars
I would top line, religious
things I would think about.
- Thank you.
Tall man at the back
who was referenced earlier.
Good luck, Louise
getting over there.
- [Man] Gary,--
- Yes?
- [Man] I'm the tall guy.
- Yes, I'm aware.
- [Man] What advice would you
give to a VP of marketing in a
brand new startup when it seems
like there's everything to do?
Where should your focus
be in the first six months?
- I think
startup marketing people,
first of all, this
is a weird thing to say.
I would tell you probably
as, and this is a generalized
statement, but I would tell
you that the marketing people at
startups that have less than
20 employees are probably the
weakest group of marketing
people I know right now.
I've been really
grossly disappointed
with the talent at that level.
Mainly 'cause startups have
not dragged down people with
experience, they'd given people
upstarts an opportunity which is
great and I love that but it
sure leaves a lot to be desired.
I would tell you the first thing
that I tell them and I speak to
a lot of them hence the thing
I'm concerned about is there's
just complete misunderstanding
of what marketing is about.
Marketing is a function
to create an action that
a company wants to happen.
So I would tell
them to reverse engineer,
like I would ask, like I asked
marketers like what you want.
I literally had conversations
where I asked a marketer in a
startup like what
you want to happen and
they can't answer it for real.
And the answer needs to be
whatever the fucking business
needs to happen tomorrow.
(audience laughter)
Right?
'Cause when you're a startup,
so the carnage that is about to
happen in startup land that
I can't wait for once we have
our next economic slowdown is
gonna be really gratifying for
me because I have become
stunningly disgusted with
what's really
happening in startup land.
Which is nobody's
building companies anymore,
everybody's just building
machines that are built for the
next round of funding.
It's crazy.
So I would tell the marketer
to do their fucking job.
I would tell her or him to say
you know what is your business
trying to do and how do you make
that happen for the
least amount of money?
- Good.
Before we go
back out to audience,
I've got a few questions
from the Facebook live stream.
Thank you guys for joining
us there around the world.
- Worldwide.
- Worldwide,
global all in one place.
But the two questions we've got,
well we've actually got quite a
few but they're along the line
of how would your personal style
work in a more
conservative U.K. market?
And then another
one to follow up with,
how does Gary see the difference
with U.K. and U.S.A. marketing?
- So I haven't played hard, like
one of the things I pride myself
in is not talk
about shit I don't know.
I haven't been, and we haven't
marketed here long enough for me
to feel comfortable on answering
the second part of the question.
I see the data.
Facebook arbitrage is
better in the U.K. market
than the U.S. market.
Every one of you should be
running Facebook ads if you want
to do business in
this market tomorrow.
Figure it out.
One test that didn't work
doesn't mean it doesn't work.
So number one, I know that from
data but still there's creative
variables that impact that.
This is a more
mature e-com market.
Everybody has their own things,
so the data supports enormous
opportunity in the U.K. market
for U.K. consumer because
there's a lot more traditional
execution going on here by the
company's yet a lot of you are
just far more advanced actually
than the American counterparts
on the way you buy
stuff through the internet.
That's a huge opportunity
as you can imagine.
On the first part,
you know listen,
I rub people wrong.
I'm too American for Americans.
(audience laughter)
So I think, you know,
on common sense there'll clearly
be some people that won't love
what I'm gonna do but
I'm not worried about that.
I have nothing but
respect for everybody.
I'm just really comfortable in
communicating with passion and
my point of views.
I want only good.
Here's what I'm grounded in
I want to build the biggest
building in town and my plan
on doing that is to build the
biggest building in town.
And I think what most people
do is tear down all the other
buildings around them.
And I think once people get
a real read on me and they
understand that's how I roll,
all the bravado and the,
you know, hustle and all that
stuff starts to become more
palpable because I'm not trying
to do it at anybody's expense.
I'm trying to when
I say, "Hey, dick face,
"you need to get serious about
this," it's because you haven't
listened to people say it nicely
for two years and that's what
I think you need to actually
maybe think about it for
30 seconds because you're
clearly not doing the right
thing so let's figure out what
communication style needs to be
deployed right now to actually
make you do something because
here's the
biggest problem I have.
My biggest competitor in
the world is your success.
The biggest problem I have is
when companies are doing good.
Good scares the shit out of me.
We're up 9%.
You know, that's scary to me
'cause that means you're not
going to do anything to change
and usually what happens after
being up 9% is not being up 9%
and it predicated on do you want
to change and be
up 15 or 19 or 22% or
do you want to be down 1%?
And so, yeah, listen,
I will pull every lever
of anything I have to do
to communicate not because
I want to be funny or 'cause
I think it's cool because I'm
desperate to help the other
person on the communication to
do something that I think is
meaningful towards
what they want to do.
- Yeah, your one-on-one
communication with like the
whole community is unparalleled.
I've not seen anybody else put
so much time in to it and it's
because it's something
you're passionate about.
- I totally agree and I'm
stunned by people's inability as
a whole to recognize it.
- Yeah.
- I'm so pissed when I get
thrown into the conversation
with huckster marketers or
other social media experts.
They don't look like me.
Like go look at them.
For huckster marketers,
I've nothing to sell you.
I got no fucking course.
There's is no mastermind.
I'm not inviting you
to my fucking island.
Like I got nothing.
I got nothing, like, nothing.
And then other social media
experts if every other social
media expert was good as me why
do I sell 100,000 copies of my
book the week it
releases on my strategies and
why do they sell a 1,000?
Like real quick on that.
All the other people that
are supposed to be experts and
social media experts, go
look at their Bookscan numbers.
If they're so fucking good and
they have such great advice,
then why can't they
sell their own fucking book?
(audience laughter)
- Why do you think then they're
not doing what you're
doing because--
- Because they're not as good
and they're not working as hard.
I am more talented
and I outwork them.
(audience laughter and applause)
That's just the real truth.
Why is the best soccer player
in the world the
best soccer player?
Because they have
the most talent and
they outworked everybody.
Because talent's not enough.
We see it all the time.
The number one pick doesn't
always be the best player
because talent's not enough
and hard work's not enough.
I could try to be the greatest
soccer player of all time,
it wasn't gonna happen.
Right, so like they
both matter and so why?
Why?
Because I like to remind
everybody that unlike every
other social media expert,
I built a $65 million business
before I came out
to the world and said,
"Hey, I'm here.
Let's talk about business."
- Where do you think
this is gonna take you?
- Me?
- Yeah.
Where is this all gonna go?
- To winning Super Bowls.
(audience laughter)
- Yeah, buying the Jets.
He's all about
buying the Jets, Stephen.
- I think realistically my dream
I love to always talk about
buying the Jets, what my real
dream is in parallel 'cause
that is my real dream is I want
to prove to the world that you
can build a financial
empire on being a good person.
I think I can change the
business landscape forever.
- Right.
- I was very affected by
Steve Jobs' run as the guy.
A lot of my tech friend
started becoming mean to their
employees because
that's what Steve did.
And it affected me a lot.
And I said, huh, I
wonder if I go and build a
multibillion-dollar thing
on being the best with the
community, the
best with my employees,
would then people
wake up and be like,
"Oh, I want to be like GaryVee
and that's what he did
"and I'm gonna do
that," and the answer is yes,
that's what people do.
And so, I'm on a
very interesting crusade.
I think, you know, I think
capitalism and meritocracy are
the greatest
truths in our society,
I do believe that and so for me
I'd like to show the world that
there is absolutely ways to be
aggressive and competitive and
want to beat your competitors
faces in the ground but be a
great guy to your team in and to
the people that surround it and
build something very meaningful
and I think I'm in
the process of doing it.
And I think what's really
intriguing about what I'm doing
is I'm documenting
it the whole way.
So, you know, it's one thing to
see my content now just project
that every day, every day,
every day 30 years from today.
You know I made a
search engine for #AskGaryVee.
I don't know if
you guys saw this.
Where which is really
incredible if you go to
ask.garyvaynerchuk.com,
I'm really proud of it.
Every word I've ever uttered
on that show is now searchable.
And the value that I'm getting
from emails and I've been,
I've been
promoting it a little bit
but I haven't
really gone in yet.
People are really
getting real value.
- Mhmmm.
- It's super cool like they're
just getting the answers to
their questions and I'm
like, wow imagine that at scale.
Imagine that, imagine all of the
words that every came out of my
mouth, this, this interview
being completely searchable
which is really cool.
I'm really excited about, I know
my intent is and I think that
for people that have known me a
long time and I see some of the
faces around here,
I know what people thought
I was 10 years ago,
seven years ago,
five years ago.
I'm only winning every day that
goes by while a lot of other
people get
exposed over that time.
- Got a question from online.
We'd like to know which
early stage
startups are doing it right?
- I don't know.
I would tell you that it depends
on how you define early stage.
Right? You know,
I think Snapchat did it really,
really, really right but
the truth is I'm not sure.
I mean which early stage
startups are doing right?
The ones that are clearly going
to be profitable with their
actual business in the next 6
to 12 months because if capital
dries up and you're living
on the next round of funding.
Guys, very big startups that we
all look up to will be out of
business 36 months from today.
They'll be out of business.
Just watch very carefully for
the following term that you're
gonna hear a lot about over
the next year: down round.
Get used to down round
which means XYZ startup,
unicorn,
got valued at $800 million
in their last round and
you just heard that they
raised new money at $325 million.
Why?
'Cause nobody was going to give
them money at a higher range and
the options work go directly out
of business or heavily lower the
valuation of your company and
get some new
money in to stay alive.
Down round will be a word you
hear over and over and over the
next 18 months because we went
way too crazy on
early stage companies.
Companies were getting A and
B funding before they had any
business which is
nothing like we've seen before.
It's completely broken
and there's gonna be enormous
opportunity and a lot of.
We also lived through a time
where the way one was deemed an
entrepreneur was predicated
on them saying they
were an entrepreneur.
(audience laughter)
which is great but
there's you know if
you said that you were a singer
or an athlete in
our society today,
they would come back and
ask you are you a
professional athlete?
Like do you get
paid to be an athlete?
But in entrepreneur land every
kid in here who's got an idea
goes, "I'm an entrepreneur."
That's nice. Are you a
professional entrepreneur?
(audience laughter)
Like do you make
money and so I think that's
about to hit its head.
At the same token, we're about
to go through the golden years
of the internet.
Internet's starting to get,
you know?
Internet's 20.
Remember when you hit 20?
Shit was starting to get cool.
20 and 30 was fun for
everybody who went through that.
You're in, I don't know if
it's your prime but fuck you are
solid and I think the internet
is about to go
through that as well.
Really the consumer web
is only 20 years old, right?
Windows 95 is kind of what
really started the version of
what were seeing now.
It's young like just rewind
like everybody this room is old
enough to just rewind just 10
years ago, most of the shit we're
talking about
right now didn't exist.
Didn't exist or was six months
in or nine months I mean like,
are you kidding me?
Like everything.
We didn't have
smart phones 10 years ago.
Now it's the only thing
that matters in our lives.
(audience laughter)
So we're just starting.
- I've got another
question from here.
- We had the Ngage 10 years ago.
- Yes.
- Remember that?
We had stuff and
you guys had texts,
you guys had
texting before we did,
right, in the U.S.
We had stuff but what do you
think the world's gonna look
like 10 years from today?
Have you looked at how a
14-year-old lives
her or his life?
What do you think
they're gonna be doing at 24?
You think they're going
to be clicking banner ads?
(audience laughter)
You think they're even
gonna know what a laptop is?
'Cause they're not.
- [Woman] Hi Gary.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Hi!
I think most
people in this room,
most people you talk to are
trying to build an
obsessive audience.
- Okay.
- [Woman] We actually
have the reverse problem.
So we have 400 million visits
to our shopping
centers in a year
so we're probably the
biggest media in the country.
- Intersting.
- Now, what we want to do is
build content and everybody's
trying to grab our audience.
Google are trying
to grab our audience,
everybody is and we want to make
sure that we get the right angle
so we can--
- Beat them.
- [Woman] have that audience and
have a relationship with them.
What's your advice on that?
- Okay, so I want to make sure.
So you guys, go a
little bit deeper.
You guys are in the retail,
bricks and mortar world, malls?
Like what are we talking about?
- [Woman] Yeah.
So we own 15 shopping malls.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Throughout the U.K.
- intu, by the way, everybody
(laughs), quick plug.
And actually the
team here everyone wave.
We run the digital
side of the business.
So we're integrating digital
content with our audience and
2/3rds of the British
population shop with us.
- [Gary] Yep.
- So we see that as an
absolutely massive opportunity.
- Of course.
Because what's gonna happen over
the next 20 to 30 years is that
number is not gonna
go in that direction.
You'll start losing that
audience over time,
and by the way,
I said two to three decades.
20, 30 years
but it will windle.
Like the 20% of e-com business
that happens in the U.S.,
30% here, that
came from somewhere.
Right, it came from physical.
It keeps getting chipped away.
It doesn't happen as fast as
Silicon Valley thinks it's gonna
happen which is why
you're still not outta business.
Whereas if this was 1996 and you
asked me in 20 years would malls
be in business I'd be like,
"Uh, they're gonna
be in real trouble."
So I think things take
longer than they think.
But I think you guys
are smart enough
to realize you're a platform.
You're a
physical platform, right?
So, first, this is a data war.
For you to have all those people
walking through your malls and
for you to not have all the data
of every one of those people,
phone, address, age,
sex is a huge problem.
And you don't have it.
So, the first thing I would do
and I'm a big
content believer, right?
Like, I think you guys
should make a reality show,
play it on Facebook 'cause
I think Facebook's the over the
top network that
Netflix doesn't want to battle.
Like I think you could do
some incredible
stuff in video production.
But before you even go there,
anybody who is being arbitraged
by the internet,
right, in the physical world,
needs to be in full
scale data collection.
Physically.
Shit, I would incentivize
every one of those 2/3rds,
3/4ths, 400 million, every one
of those people like tomorrow as
leaders in the
company from a digital side,
you need to have conversations
with leaders in
the whole organization.
You should absolutely
incentivize data
collection at scale.
Fucking every food court item
should be cheaper if they have
your card so you get
the data or the app or what.
I should be able to park in a
better spot if I have the app.
Let me unlock with my app and
I will trade you data for time.
Right? You have to.
It's super
great that you have 3,
400 million
people walking through.
They're not yours.
And you can make them yours.
Ironically, they're the
shops in your malls people,
not yours but you can
actually arbitrage that,
have that, own that data and
then build the next version of
yourself when and if we
stop going to those places.
And by the way, and I think you
guys are smart enough to know
this, there are a lot of markets
where malls are
in very big trouble.
If you go look at the
Australian market with malls,
parts of middle
America right now,
it's already starting to happen
and so I always think people are
gonna go to physical places,
I just think that every day that
goes by a mall's model is
vulnerable and you should siphon
the data starting tomorrow.
- [Woman] Can I push back?
- Of course.
- [Woman] So the way we
see malls going is leisure,
dining, experience--
- Agreed. Agreed.
- [Woman] so what we're
seeing with our stores and our
retailers that are there,
so Nike perfect example,
they're creating brand
experiences within the malls--
- You're 100% right.
- [Woman] that are totally
immersive and the thing is--
- You and I agree.
- [Woman] people love a free day
out and a coffee at Starbucks.
- 100%.
- [Woman] And go into Nike.
So we don't think
malls are going anywhere.
We haven't seen
our footfall move.
- Yep.
- [Woman] But actually,
personally I think the big,
massive, huge opportunity
is not VR but AR.
- Yep.
- [Woman] So contact
lenses, walk into the store.
- 100%.
- [Woman] Try it on, order my
size there and then and you
know, could we be that
platform for everybody?
- So let's play this out.
Let's talk this out.
Because this is fun now.
(audience laughter)
I agree with you
because we both agree the
way mall today is as a
transactional center is not
gonna work and it will evolve
and retail has evolved
through all time. Right?
It's all different things.
The thing that I'm most
fascinated by is how top-heavy
do the experiences become?
So Nike, I know for a fact,
is not super interested
in driving your
overall experience.
They're starting to
look at locations in U.S.,
they're entire U.S.
retail strategy
is no more malls,
standalone Nike.
We're fucking Nike.
People are coming to
the mall because of us.
It's part of their
strategy, that just 100%.
That's not my
opinion. That's 100%.
Now the question
becomes how does that play out?
Over time how does that play out
because what you're saying is,
you're 100% right.
We are all gonna
experience, right?
The question will become will
the top 50 brands in the world
that will have 80% of the
leverage want to keep paying
you in arbitrage when they
are the absolute
driver of that experience?
That, to me, is a far more
interesting question. Right?
Because when it
becomes too top-heavy,
which it will,
the question will
become what is it
actually look like?
Because malls are great but
there's a lot of land out there
and to pay you a vig for
something that I'm actually
driving and then I'm arb'ing to
other competitive products as
people start competing with each
other in multiple categories
becomes very fascinating.
Because not only does Nike have
this but it's very intriguing
that Starbucks has opened it's
first 10 standalone
stores this year.
This is an arb game always and
so I understand why you would
like it to be that way 'cause
that's the business you're in.
The same way I want
things to be the way
I want them to
be for my business.
I think the fun debate if we're
really having this battle is
when it tips to a small
group of having the leverage,
it's no different than why
Amazon is now private
labeling every category.
It got big enough in the U.S.
market to have enough data
to now compete with their own
partners and so malls are
not competing with e-commerce,
malls are competing with the
seven players that represent 80%
of the experiences in 15 years
saying themselves I'm not
overpaying you guys for that
so I can support the other 10
cockamamie
characters in this room when
everybody's coming for me.
- Should malls become
content creators as well then?
- Yeah, I think when you're at
that big of a scale and you have
that big of a
company I think everybody
should be in the media business.
- Mhmmm.
- And so, I literally
think you should do a sit-com.
- I would watch it.
I would watch it.
- I really do and I think
you should
distribute it on Facebook.
How many people
here watch DailyVee?
It's a TV show being distributed
on Facebook and YouTube.
And now, how many of you
watch it on a television?
So this is interesting,
so this is interesting.
Very small number.
One, one and a half, two, maybe
three but in
three years all of you.
Like we're so close, right?
What happens when Facebook
makes a TV where you just in
your stream hit a button and
it shows up on your TV? Right?
We're very, very, very close.
My new Samsung TV, which Lizzie
bought against my will, 'cause I
have my Samsung joke
that some of you have heard,
I was, I didn't
know we got a new TV.
I'm laying in bed, looking, I'm
approving the new DailyVee and
it's so amazing what your eye,
it's amazing when you get used
to something UI/UX-wise that if
something changes you're like
what was that?
And you don't even,
it's subconscious right?
You're so used to it.
I'm in the app,
it's not launched yet.
I have to approve it,
make sure, you know,
DailyVee's super scary for me by
the way for all we make 'cause
I'm in real business
meetings and one word slip,
one name slip, so I have
to actually watch these
before they come out.
First time I've ever
watched my own content,
it's kind of weird.
And I'm like,
"What the fuck is that?"
There's like this weird icon,
I click it and then fucking
DailyVee's playing on my TV.
Zero friction.
And I said holy shit
this would work for my mom.
And that's when
I know we're close.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Did you see, did you test LBI?
They're now doing I think it's
three times a week they're doing
a morning show live on Facebook.
- 100%.
- It's going there.
Do a sit-com.
I'm 100% behind that idea
for this sit-com as well.
- Down in the front here.
Good luck, Louise.
(audience laughter)
- Pass the mic on.
- [Gabrielle] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- [Gabrielle] Hello.
I'm Gabrielle Baker and I am
probably alone here in that I'm
in the creative
space as a voice actor.
I don't think there's
any voice actors here.
But, I'm slightly
techie as well.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gabrielle] And I'm very
into social media and I've been
following Gary
for few years now.
And I really enjoyed your Fiverr
#AskGaryVee the other day.
Mainly because the guy had such
a gorgeous voice and I loved
listening to it on my podcast.
But in my community there's
so much hatred for Fiverr and
I've stopped talking about it
because I get these disgusted looks.
- Are you kidding? I have
literally death mail from
designers in my inbox
from the Fiverr episode.
- [Gabrielle] Because we
don't like to work cheap.
- Because they're losers.
- [Gabrielle] Yeah.
- And let me explain why I say
that and I'm thrilled and
I know everybody's watching.
Any time you're mad that there's
a marketplace that drives down
the cost of your craft and you
don't realize that if you're the
best at your craft
that has no impact on you,
you're a losing romantic.
There's people that--
- But we're accused of damaging
the industry if we market
ourselves on Fiverr.
You're bringing us all down.
You're bringing the rate down.
You're killing the industry.
- A lot of
people like Communism.
(audience nervous laughter)
- Feel free to tweet that.
- Guys, guys, guys like
I get paid $80,000
to give a speech
and do shit like this.
I did this for free.
I get to decide what I do.
You don't get to decide.
Like the speaking coaches, the
speaking bureaus of the world
don't get to tell me to
do this for free or not.
- You decide.
- I decide.
- So should I use a
pseudonym for a 5 buck gig?
- [Gary] No, I think everybody
should do what
they have to do but--
- Just as a platform
to sort of advertising.
- [Gary] It's elitist at
best. It's elitist at best.
I have a huge community
that makes no money.
Maybe you've been seeing this
and it's been weird it's this
little niche
thing I've been doing,
I've been pushing
this eBay thing, right?
You know why?
Because I'm getting a thousand
fucking emails a week from
people like, "Gary
this $200 I made this week,
"like I'm feeding my kids."
Like, "I bought a nice
shirt for the first time."
Like who are you
designer to tell people that
they can't make a $5 design?
Just 'cause you have it
good and you can get $500?
They don't have any money
and they have no awareness.
And they don't know how to get
people to buy their $5 logo.
So here's a platform.
You gonna be made at eBay?
You gonna be
mad at the internet?
You gonna be mad that the car
was invented
when you had horses?
(audience laughter)
You gonna be mad
when VR comes along and
wipes out all the
internet businesses?
Should we feel bad for News Corp
that the internet came along and
Facebook and
Snapchat came along?
Should I cry for MTV
'cause Snapchat came along?
We're thrilled to laugh at big
companies that get arbitraged
'cause it's in our benefit but
when it hits home, oh.
And so, that's Nazi Germany.
Oh, it's just the
Gypsies, who gives a shit?
I'm not a Gypsy.
Oh, it's just the Jews?
I'm not a Jew, who cares?
- [Gabrielle] And
it's not $5 anymore. Is it?
Because you can--
- If it's one cent.
Fucking if they keep yelling
at me I'm gonna start a website
where people do shit for free.
(audience laughter)
Because I do shit
for free now and I'm rich
as fuck and I don't have to
because I think it's in my
vested interest for the exposure
or the context or I'm trying to
build relationships
in a new market.
I get to decide not your
fucking elitist fucking opinion.
Get the fuck out of here.
(audience laughter)
Fucking pisses me off.
- [Gabrielle] Thank you.
- So Adam, we're
sitting here next to GaryVee,
he just did the rant,
how cool with that?
- It was a good rant.
- That was great.
- [Gabrielle] By the
way, Gary, I've got--
- By the way, let me
say something real quick.
And I respect people's
opinions on the other side.
I respect it, I respect it.
I do, like everybody has,
they're more than entitled.
I don't think I'm right.
I think I'm right for me.
And I just don't
want somebody to tell me
what I can and can not do.
But like, we have to
recognize market behaviors.
They're real.
There's people
that get paid
$100,000 a day to
shoot photography.
And then there's
people that do it for free.
That's just the game.
And I think what people don't
understand is there's a lot of
people that are at zero.
They're at zero and like some of
these platforms can help and by
the way, I don't,
I'm not standing up.
I don't give a
fuck about Fiverr.
Fuck Fiverr.
This isn't about Fiverr.
This is about
marketplace dynamics.
This is about capitalism.
This is about who am I as a
human being to
tell you what to do?
You do you.
You guys have been seeing this
from me more and more lately.
I'm not telling you
to work 18 hours a day.
You might get divorced.
Like I don't want that.
I don't want an
email in 20 years saying,
"I listened to you.
I made a million bucks
"but my kids hate you, hate me."
Like I don't want that.
I'm telling you what I do.
You can use it as a context
point and figure out what you
think but let me
just say one thing,
hard work always
is gonna matter.
I just want to make sure
that part doesn't get lost.
I'm sorry but it's true.
Like it's just forever.
Forever like there is nobody,
there's nobody who
did it on no hard work.
It just hasn't happened.
Show me, show me.
You know, I made that video
the other day I guess it was a
DailyVee and it
opened with Beyoncé,
people love,
Beyoncé's got it so great.
Beyoncé worked her
fucking face off since she was,
her fucking dad made her dance
since she was four
every day of her life.
Like everybody sees
what it's at when it's good.
You guys see this now.
I didn't have a
fuckin' childhood.
I worked every
minute from 14 to 30,
all of them.
Like, you know and so like
I think that we have
to factor in these things.
- Yeah.
I have a question that's come
in from Twitter from one our
bloggers here, from one of
our actual writers Dom Burch.
He recently wrote an
article about is it time to call
bullshit on
influencer marketing.
- Right.
- He wants to know
your thoughts on it.
- I think influencer marketing
is one of the best
deals in the world.
- There it is.
- So I guess, now,
now, now to that point,
to that point we have to get
into details a lot of
this is headline reading.
I think there's a ton of
influencers that are overpaid.
I'm obsessed with the long
tail of influencer marketing.
There are so many people
with 300 to 3,000 followers on
Instagram that will do so much
good for your business you would
not believe and there's people
that have 100,000 followers and
good engagement too by the way,
it's not just the bought 'em,
good engagement but they've
pimped every fucking thing under
the sun so the depth of their
promotion or
sponsorship is not real.
I've never pimped
anything so when I do it,
it would mean something and then
somebody will posts some sort of
fucking waist thing and fucking
tea shit and fucking all that
shit that you see 24/7 you
know after you see them pimp
something 98 days in a row
you just might not take their
opinion for as much
value as somebody else, right?
And so, I think that I'm very
hot on influencer marketing.
I think it's,
I just attention arbitrage.
Show me a human being that's got
a big audience in a niche that
I'm trying to reach and she or
he doesn't know how to price the
value of their distribution and
I'll show you a very happy kid
that loves those
kind of scenarios.
- I've got gentleman second row.
Been waiting patiently.
- [Man] Hey Gary.
- Hey brother.
- [Man] '97, '98 I had a
Frank Zappa quote on the front
of my master's dissertation
on the future of publishing.
And I'm gonna tell you
that Frank Zappa quote and
then I have a question for you.
- Please.
- The algorithm can tell you a
story but can't tell you the
whole story, it just
doesn't have the eyebrows.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Who do you think
today has the eyebrows?
- I think that's a
really cool, that's really cool.
So I think the people that have
the eyebrows are the ones that
are not romantic around the
subjectiveness of the art and
realizes there is a process to
create a lot of the art to get
context on what the
consumer actually wants.
So what he's referring to I
think and help me here I believe
that the art of
marketing, right,
the creative is the magic.
It's the variable.
It 100% is.
It's not the math, right?
However, I believe that there is
now the opportunity to create a
lot of the art,
bubble it up at scale,
not be romantic that you're the
only human being that knows
the voice or the brand
or the right song.
Put it out and let the audience,
do you know how
much more successful,
Drake the artist.
This mother fucker's put out
like 80 songs this year already.
Do you know how smart that is?
Do you know what he's doing?
Why it's so smart?
Every artist that we know,
all those Prince songs,
right, that are in the vault.
In 2016, Prince would
have put them all out.
What you're gonna see from all
your artists is if they believe
in it, they're gonna put it out.
They're not gonna be stuck to
the you need 12 songs in the
album or some fucking partner
at Sony music saying what's this
album, what story
is this album telling?
I mean so the people that have
the eyebrows that are the ones
that realize that the art is the
magic but let's cut some of the
bullshit out of the the
human bullshit out of the art.
- Okay, we've not got a lot of
time left so we're gonna take
one more from the floor.
We'll take one more from online.
- Yeah.
- And then we'll
finish up. Louise, you choose.
- I'm feeling good.
I'm willing to be
10 or 15 minutes late.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I would do this all day.
- Okay, Louise would you just
happily pass the mic along.
There we go.
- Oh, new system, the pass.
I was literally when she's gonna
figure out the pass is the game.
- We're gonna learn.
- [Kevani] Hi Gary.
- That was a good pass.
- [Kevani] My name's Kevani.
I'm 18, I'd left
secondary school,
high school
around 10 months ago.
Since then I've co-founded an
app that basically allows guys
to pre-book any barber
whilst being
rewarded for their loyalty.
We are, a majority of our
team is black from the African,
Caribbean community.
- [Gary] Love it.
- Understand you
grew up in Jersey,
around the hip hop
renaissance 80s.
- [Gary] I did.
- I want to know how you suggest
we represent our culture without
exclusivising ourselves.
- I want to make sure
I caught the last part.
How we represent
our culture with what?
- Without
exclusivising ourselves.
'Cause if you look
at companies like FUBU.
- [Gary] Yep.
- They were very black.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Their consumers
were very black.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But hip hop was used
to grow brands like Adidas,
Puma, not really stuff that
belonged to our community.
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- So how would you
suggest we do that?
- I think it really comes
down to what you guys and gals,
I don't know your team but
what do you want to accomplish?
- We want to revolutionize
the barber industry.
We want every barber
to be booked through our.
- Well then, I think you need
to think about every culture and
every person because
you're trying to boil the ocean.
So I think there's a
lot of ways to do that.
Look, I think, and this has
obviously become a little bit
more of a topic because I've
been doing more stuff in the
hip hop, you know,
I did the Breakfast Club and
that got ridiculous.
And so that brought
people awareness and
they're like wait a minute.
And then people scoured my
Instagram and are like why is
Gary have all these
college friends that are black?
(audience laughter)
All this stuff.
So this conversation
has bubbled up a little bit.
I truly believe what
I'm about to say which is,
one, I think entrepreneurship
is rugged and is very raw.
And I actually believe the more
disadvantages you had growing
up, it's a better
proxy for success.
So I've made more money on
female entrepreneur-backed
companies than any
thing else I've ever done.
I just want to win
so I could care less--
(audience member applauds)
You like that one?
(audience laughter)
I'll tell you that
I'm far quicker to not
want to do business with a
New England Patriots founder
than black or a girl or an alien
or anything, you know,
so I think that,
I think there's
a couple things about.
Number one, I think that you
have to bet on strengths which
is where I'm going.
So I think one when you're a
minority or when you have the
fight harder than a white dude,
I think you need the first of
all channel that chip.
I think I'm successful and
I think a lot of people are
successful in
channeling adversity.
Number two, if your goal is
to revolutionize
the barber industry,
I think what you
do is you win on
your actions and nothing else.
Meaning just building a
successful business is the best
thing you can do for the
question that you just asked
because I think spending any
time or energy on the narrative
is not going to
accomplish anything
in revolutionizing
the barber industry.
There's one amazing
thing about the market,
the market, the market the one
I love so much based on your
question, the
one I love so much,
they don't care who invented it.
If it's good for
them they want it.
They're just real like that.
That's what I love
about the market.
The market is the only
thing that's not prejudice.
It's the market like they just
want what's good for them and
they don't care
who the founder was.
You don't know who the
founder is of anything you got.
Like you don't know the
back story of anything you're
wearing, using, buying.
You just want what you want.
And so, I would tell you the
best thing you could do is
actually just
build a big business.
And not worry about that
narrative because I think if
I cared about doing something
right for the Russian Jewish
immigrant community, being
successful is the best thing
I could've done. Right?
So I would tell you that.
Now on the same token, I'll tell
you them probably gonna leave a
lot of money on the table in
my life because I much more
passionate about having a legacy
of helping entrepreneurs than
I do in maximizing a couple
hundred more million dollars.
If you have passion around the
narrative of what you can do,
rise up others
in your community,
then you start spending some
of that time and energy on it.
Two things, one, first build the
business 'cause it'll give you
leverage to do
that later and two,
once you feel like you got a
foundation where all of you have
got a little something
and you're feeling good,
then you can start trickling
some of that stuff
'cause it all takes energy.
It's all opportunity costs.
Like this right here tonight is
at the expense of something else
I could be doing and there's
millions of things I could be
doing that would be making
me more short-term money.
There's millions of things
I could be doing that could
build my brand bigger.
To me, this market, these guys,
was the right vibe when we met
for drinks of the founder.
This community,
like so you know,
you make your decisions but
I would tell you I asked you a
very specific question
'cause it's the right question.
If you want to
revolutionize that industry.
That's for everybody and
that needs to be
what you focus on first.
You can get back to doing the
right thing for your community
three, four, five, six years
from today not doing anything
except building the business
'cause you'll use that leverage
to actually do it.
I have a second
question for you, sorry.
- [Gary] Okay.
- At this age you
were probably quite
similar minded
to someone like me.
Quite entrepreneurial,
trying to set up a business.
How do you balance the patience
and the
impatience at this point?
- You know I,
and I'm glad you asked that
and tall dude referenced it.
One of the best things that
I think I've done for young
entrepreneurs is tell them
that my addiction is patience.
How'd I balance it?
'Cause I knew it mattered.
Like all you kids are fucking
up because you want shit now.
- Yeah.
- And you will lose every time.
You lack practicality.
You want shit now.
You're 18.
If you get nothing
for the next 12 years,
just fucking eat shit,
grind, hustle, do it.
Nothing.
You'll be 30.
(audience laughter)
- [Stephen] And?
- I mean I would
rip my arm off to be 30.
I'll give you my
arm for 10 years.
For 10 years,
I'll give you my arm.
- [Adam] Take me back.
- So, I would tell
you how did I balance it?
Because I'm a winning player.
Because I know how to
build million dollar things.
And million dollar things
don't happen with shortcuts.
- Yeah.
- Good luck.
That sounds like a business.
- Perfect answer.
Before you put
the microphone down,
do you want to be on one of
these shows 'cause you seem
like an interesting individual
and what you're doing seems
amazing as well.
- Wow.
- Sweet, we'll talk afterwards.
(audience applause)
- Okay.
- Secondly, you do business
with somebody from outer space
instead of a
New England Patriots fan?
- Yeah, I mean there's
nothing worse on Earth than
a New England Patriots fan.
(audience laughter)
- I'm a Dolphins
fan so it's fine.
(crosstalk)
- Let's keep going
unless you guys are stuck.
- Can I come to you
after going to the internet?
- Yeah.
- Just dive through.
We've had loads
and loads of questions
coming in since we last got one.
Somebody asking
would you rehire them.
I was like I'll
go past that one.
- Is that true?
Oh my God, I'm love Jeremy.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Jeremy send me an
email. Send me an email.
That's amazing.
- There we go.
That's fantastic.
Jobs!
- That's awesome Jeremy.
- We got loads of
questions, I'm gonna pick,
where do you the e-commerce
will be heading
in the next five years
or what advice would you
give recruiters looking to grow
their social presence
to engage with candidates?
- I think recruiters
need to prove to us
what value do they bring.
And so I think recruiters
would be very
smart to put out content.
And content they
would normally, so,
the number one advice I have for
people that sell their services
is to give it away
for free on the internet.
Let me explain.
I give all of you all my best
marketing advice every day.
I have agency competitors,
I have other people that take my
content repackage it,
market against
GaryVee fans on Facebook
and sell it back to them for
$400 e-books and
my fucking fans buy it.
(audience laughter)
Yeah. You know
how much that hurts?
But, I don't care.
It's the right
strategy and here's why.
A, and this is
gonna blow your mind,
98% of people aren't gonna
do anything about it anyway.
That's the crazy one.
B, if you keep doing it, if you
keep doing it something innately
human takes over and
people start understanding the
difference between the people
that provide value and people
that are trying to take value.
And I'm winning on that.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Because the one thing that
people haven't really figured
out of what I'm actually doing
is my behavior is one big case
study in the difference between
branding and
marketing versus sales.
If you look at what I've done
over the last five to seven
years versus what a lot of
people that look
like me have done,
they've tried to
transact you and monetize you
and I haven't.
I've tried to
build a brand on you.
And what ends up happening is
I end up winning that race in
the long term because
your word of mouth,
your appreciation, your support,
trumps the short term returns
that other people do.
So if I was a recruiter,
I'd be putting out advice.
You may think you've got three
little things that you tell a
candidate about your resume,
about something that that's the
secret sauce and
you've converted well.
That shit needs to go in public
and get shared and then bring
more people to you, not less.
Because what people haven't
understood is advice,
in general,
the way I'm doing it
right now, can only be so good.
Right, like that's why I do Q&amp;A
because I can add three or four
more context levers where you
may not agree with me or
where we need to
finish the thought and
we end up being in
a more similar place,
we're in a
different place or
something that
I can round value around.
Every recruiter can give their
best advice but then when they
meet you are gonna listen to
you and have to give me three or
four other data pieces of advice
that they could never
do with their content.
But they haven't
figured that out.
They think they're
in the advice business
so why would I give it away?
Back to Fiverr,
I give everything away.
Fiverr haters.
You know and so
that's what I would do.
As far as were
e-commerce is going,
I think they're gonna
put malls out of business.
I'm kidding. Kidding.
(audience laughter)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
How many people in e-com or
flirt with it or play with it?
Not a lot of
people here, a couple?
Yeah, it's true, right.
I couldn't imagine not making
every decision today around
e-com based on a mobile only
environment and
I don't mean iPad,
I mean your cell phone.
So that would be the
number one thing I would say.
For you to be in e-com and not
every behavior you're doing is
okay, 84% of our business is
desktop and 16 is mobile,
but let's do everything in our
business right now with it being
about mobile and all the
business we get from desktop is
gravy until the shift.
- Do we have
any recruiters here?
- Nope.
- 'Cause that's basically all
I get from recruiters
is stuff like that.
(audience laughter)
And if you just stop
doing that and listen to you.
- What does it say?
- Oh, it's I'd like to add
you to my network on LinkedIn.
It's just Batman and Bane.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I mean look, I mean
spamming people on LinkedIn is
not a marketing strategy.
- There's so many
recruiters still do it.
- 'Cause it works.
Because people
hate their fucking jobs.
They're like, "Oh,
hope this guy can help me."
(audience laughter)
But pay attention
to what I'm saying
'cause those were
two contradictions.
So that's a recruiter
that's gonna win on
sales and transactions.
The one that listens to
my advice wins on brand.
Right, the reason I sell 100,000
copies of my book the first week
and not 1,000 like all the other
people is they're transacting
and I'm marketing.
- Cool. Stephen.
- Gentleman here.
- That t-shirt is amazing.
But not at the same time.
- I love it.
- [Rafal] Hi.
Thanks for being here, thanks
for doing what you're doing over
the last couple of years online.
I've got three things
that will try to be very fast.
- [Gary] No problem.
- First of all my name is Rafal.
I came to the U.K.
around 10 years ago.
I'm from Poland.
So it's kind of like you,
I was born in
Communistic Poland.
- [Gary] Yes.
- In mid-80s.
For the first five years, I was
doing different kind of day jobs
here and over the last five
years I do my own business.
I started as a photographer,
then I went into
video and I'm doing okay.
That's my project
that supports me,
my wife and our
family so that's good.
Over the last year and
especially the last couple of
months, I started
doing much more
200, 300, 500% more than
I was doing last year and
suddenly there was
no much time to sleep.
(laughs)
I've got my passion
which is video and I have
another source of income
which I'm starting which is in
financial market and
that would bring me
much more money
than my passion.
How to find a
balance between--
- Family, passion, income.
- [Rafal] 22 hours of work.
- Yep.
- [Rafal] Between what I like
to do between what I know would
bring me much more money.
- Yep.
Yeah, it's a great question.
- [Rafal] Keeping it growing.
- First and foremost it starts
with you communicating
with your wife.
First and foremost.
That is the
most important thing.
- [Rafal] She's
on board, she's fine.
- (laughs) So she's benefiting.
- But it's super important.
Like, first of all you have to
make sure that you're creating
the environment for
her to tell you the truth.
Right, because she may be in a
position where sure but maybe
it'd be nice to have date night
or more time with the kids or,
and this is
something that
Lizzie and I go
through every day.
I'm always trying to
create more protection.
I did it very
aggressively this weekend.
Where I'm like, this last six
months has been really like,
like I'm even scared that I'm
so on this high that I've been
thinking about how
am I gonna stop this.
Like 'cause this
is not sustainable.
I don't even
want this for myself.
Like the way
I'm going right now,
over the last six months,
I don't even want it.
But what's crazy is like
it's fucking like, right?
Like the high is so
intense I'm like fuck,
the coming off that
high is gonna be hard.
- [Rafal] I know what you
mean. Sometimes it's 2 A.M.
I don't want to go to
sleep but I know I need to.
- So I will say one thing, this
is a good opportunity for me.
Let's make sure we get this on
my Snapchat 'cause
I want to get this.
This is my next
thing I'm gonna pound.
I'm a huge fan of sleep.
I'm a big believer in sleep and
I think everybody
should sleep a lot.
I mean it.
I'm actually trying to sleep
six or seven hours every day.
It's not happening for me all
the time but I'll sleep 10 hours
if I can from a
Friday to a Saturday.
Sleeps massively important.
I'm more worried what
you're doing while your awake.
Right?
I'm worried about people lolly
gagging and bullshitting and
playing "Candy
Crush" and fucking,
you know, that.
But sleep I'm all in on.
I think it's
communication. Right?
I think it's balance.
And I think the other thing that
you guys have to figure out and
it's for everybody.
Everybody has their own thing.
You can't worry about what other
people's relationships are.
You've got you guys, you've got
your feelings towards what you
want to do professionally.
Your kids, money.
And you have to understand
the most important part,
it changes every day.
There's no rule.
There's no,
in those three things,
more money,
passion, family, right?
33, 33, 33.
Tomorrow 40, 7,
like, you can't figure this out.
This is, there is no
work-life balance.
There is no
happiness-money balance.
There's all of us just
trying to do the best we can.
What won for me and what I'm
trying to push harder and try to
figure out how to communicate
this to you is do
you know yourself.
That's when you start winning.
I know who I am and then that's
why I'm able to do what I do
because I'm always picking the
thing that makes me the happiest
and then I'm just making sure
that everybody around me
that's affected by that,
where do they sit
on that pendulum of
being okay with it.
Because if I'm not
doing what's best for me,
well then I can't support
everything else and,
as you can imagine in my life,
I support a lot of things.
And so I'm,
you know, it's just constant,
it's a living and
breathing thing and
it will never be solved.
It just once you make that
decision and you realize it can
ebb and flow and you have to
know how to concede at times,
you have to patient.
You know?
I love calling patience but
then I'm in my own like momentum
moment I'm like okay to be
patient and so you just fight
but there's, I'm not gonna be
able to answer that for you.
Nobody is.
You gotta
answer it for yourself.
And I would say the other thing
is every time you're not feeling
good, tweak the numbers.
Every time, that's what I do.
You haven't heard from me maybe
ever for the people that watch
me hard-core saying
I don't want to go at this pace.
It's because in the
last week or two I'm like
I don't want to go at this pace.
Like 20 hours, I need to figure
out like this fall I'd really
like to pick one day a week
where I go home at 6 o'clock
just stay home.
Like I'm really
trying to figure it out.
We'll see.
- [Rafal] I agree.
It is a choice and we try to
have at least once a week date
night and stuff like that to
make sure that's happening.
- [Gary] That's huge.
By the way, by the way.
- [Stephen] Hold him to it.
- And by the way,
I've gone months
without having that with Lizzie.
- [Rafal] We're trying. Not
every time we made it happen.
- It is what it is.
It is what it is.
- And another one, quick one.
- [Stephen] Double bubble.
- Very quick.
I would like to be and do what
I can to help you if you need me
to be your DRock in
the U.K. or in Europe.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I do video,
yeah, and I can do it.
- [Gary] Great.
- I'm more than.
- [Gary] Gary@VaynerMedia.com
say you're the guy with the
"Ideas Are Shit" shirt and I'll
get you connected with DRock and
we'll figure it out.
- [Rafal] Okay.
Let's speak.
- So I'm well aware that our
three bosses have been standing
for an hour and
15 minutes to make sure
everyone else got seats.
Thank you bosses.
- Thank you bosses.
- Stay standing.
- So we are going to
close with one final question.
- Okay.
- What's next for you?
(audience laughter)
Other than sleep?
Other than sleep, what's
next for Gary Vaynerchuk?
- I'm a counterpuncher.
I'm a counterpuncher and when
you're a counterpuncher you have
no fucking idea
what's coming at you.
You know?
And that's who I am
and so what will be
next is what's always
been which is I'm really good
at understanding white
spaces in consumer behavior.
The stuff that you
guys are not thinking about,
don't realize or don't realize
you're gonna do and I like to
pay attention to
that human behavior.
I like to figure out how to
story tell whatever I want to
tell in that platform and
then I become a
practitioner when I see it.
And then I test and
learn, I test and learn.
The stuff I'm learning about
Musical.ly right now may work
for me if Musical.ly becomes the
next Snapchat or may work for me
in three years when something
similar-ish to it and the things
I learned from
Musical.ly in the way that
I learned a lot from SocialCam.
You remember that
five minutes? You know?
That app was very hot for
literally five minutes but it
became the foundation of what
Snapchat and Instagram video and
Vine and I learned.
And so,
what's next is enormous
amounts of listening while
everybody thinks all
I'm doing is talking.
- Well, we've all been listening
and it's been fascinating.
Before we finish just would like
to say a quick congratulations.
Adam's just been
promoted this month
to Head of Social for The Drum.
Well done him.
(audience applause
and cheers)
Well deserved.
- Thank you.
You shouldn't have.
Oh you.
- I'll let you finish up.
- Yeah.
Because this was
a live recording,
I'm gonna finish it
off like it is a TV show.
- You got it.
- Shit! What do I do?
(audience laughter)
Thank you very much
for Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for
coming along and
Stephen Lepitak, my guest.
- Oh thank you.
- Take that.
This has been another edition,
a special one of SM Buzz Chat.
- Let's be honest, the best.
(audience laughter)
- This has been the second
best edition of SM Buzz Chat.
- Can I ask a quick question?
You were recently
interviewed by Larry King,
what was a better
experience this or Larry King?
- This was better.
- Yeah.
(audience applause)
- Because there
was humans in here.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Who, what did you
think was the best one?
- No, you are the best one.
It's fine.
- Okay.
- It's fine.
It's fine.
Ooh, fuck. Jesus.
- Right, close up, close up.
- So, thank you very much for
Gary Vaynerchuk joining me for
the best SM Buzz
Chat we've ever had.
Wink.
We'll be back, we have
another episode very soon.
- Not as good as this one.
- What? Won't be as good--
- This is not just the best,
this is the best
one you'll ever have.
(audience laughter)
- It's the worst
ending to one ever.
- Should we do it again?
- No, keep it.
- Thank you very much for
Gary Vaynerchuk for joining me
this has been the best episode
and is the last episode we're
gonna do 'cause it's
never gonna get any better.
- Never gonna get better.
- Bye everyone.
- But if you liked this we
could probably
start doing stuff again.
Follow us @TheDrum,
@BuzzAwards on Twitter.
I've been Adam Libonatti-Roche,
@baconchin,
go on explain.
Say who you are on Twitter
or Snapchat or Instagram and
Pinterest and Vine.
- Don't need it.
(audience laughter)
- I don't need it either.
- Thank you to our
live studio audience.
- Thank you guys.
- And it's been lovely.
(audience applause)